es una nueva escalada en la guerra en
Ucrania ahora en forma de movilización
militar por parte de Rusia que planea
Llamar a sus filas hasta 300.000
soldados reservistas
repito solo estamos hablando de una
movilización parcial en un anuncio a la
nación el presidente Vladimir Putin
aprovechó para lanzar una amenaza velada
a occidente defenderá los referendos de
anexión ucranianos y la integridad
territorial de Rusia incluso con armas
nucleares declaraciones que Ucrania no
tardó en condenar la única respuesta
apropiada a las amenazas beligerantes de
Rusia es duplicar el apoyo a Ucrania más
sanciones a Rusia más armas a Ucrania
más solidaridad con los ucranianos más
negocios abandonando Rusia más
determinación para hacer a Rusia
responsable
despertando también indignación entre la
comunidad internacional y todos los
aliados de Ucrania lo que muchos piensan
es el último resorte de Rusia ante las
recientes batallas perdidas en terreno
el discurso es una escalada pero no una
sorpresa
el discurso del presidente Putin
demuestra que la guerra no se está
desarrollando según sus planes ha
cometido un gran error de cálculo
todo en medio de la asamblea general de
las Naciones Unidas de Nueva York Rusia
ha violado descaradamente los principios
fundamentales de la carta de Naciones
Unidas y que también ha generado
malestar en la propia Rusia allí casi
6.000 soldados ya han muerto y muchos no
quieren ir a la guerra
siempre sientes preocupaciones Porque
tienes una esposa e hijos y piensas en
ello no me gustaría dejarlos en caso de
que pase algo
motivo por el que la población salió a
protestar en las calles de Moscú un
delito según la fiscalía rusa que ahora
puede llegar a costar varios años de
prisión en el país